well it's important because well it's
just it's knowledge the knowledge of
numbers um
the algebraic numbers are
the ones that we've we're the most
familiar with
but in a sense
there's hardly any of them compared to
transcendental numbers
algebraic numbers are actually countable
or listable as another way of saying it
so it's actually quite a small infinity
it's the smallest infinity but on the
real number line
you've got a bigger infinite
it just so happens that most of the
numbers on the real number line are
transcendental
and we didn't know that until we
discovered transcendental numbers
so this is really recent information in
terms of the long history of maths that
humanity's been covering over two
thousand years
this is a new fact
and what this meant the trends and the
the transcendence of pi i like that the
transcendence of pi actually answered
some really interesting questions there
were some really old questions that the
greeks had about squaring the circle
okay so how can you make um a circle of
a particular area turn that into a
square and there was lots of ways that
they try to do it with straight edge and
compass
but all those things every attempt they
do actually ends up being an algebraic
equation right
so
they were saying how can we turn pi so
pi is linked in that how can we turn pi
um into another thing by using algebra
well it just
it shows that you can't because it's
transcendental there's something really
tricky going on
and that's why i like it because the the
tricky stuff is where all the awesome
maths is well the thing is with pi
pi is about perfection
and there are no perfect circles
in our universe
none so we don't really you don't need
pi
per se you can get by with 3.14
or like you know 29 digits to do like
the biggest theoretical ring around the
universe or something like that
so and anything that truncates like any
decimal that ends is a fraction because
it's just that number divided by one
with how many zeros
and so we're dealing with fractions
there's you know fractions we know how
to deal with fractions there's a
difference between dealing with big
numbers and dealing with these very
strange numbers but see this stuff is
just to do with maths
but just to show you the power of it i
mean the construction of say euler's
identity
i mean this thing is all hanging
together
with infinitely sharp
perfection like it's not it's not a
number near e or a number near pi i mean
these are the numbers
and there is a specific value for that
so it's really really important we get
these things right in maths
perfection is important but then anyone
who uses maths for physics or chemistry
or whatever you want to do
you know then they can kind of use
approximations i'm not interested in
approximations
you